[Musique]
on ne va surtout pas généraliser mais si
en fait être noir à moscou c'est un
petit peu plus fort qu'ailleurs et il
faut savoir courir vite car ici les
attaques contre les noirs sont assez
régulière on va dire comme ça avec un
gouvernement qui nous totalement le
raciste dans le pays qui ne fait rien
pour décourager les ultra nationalistes
alors à moscou avant d'être nigérian
camerounais sénégalais on est avant tout
africain on se regroupe on s'entraide on
se protège notamment au sein d'une
université qui est une fierté de la
ville l'université de l'amitié entre les
peuples rouge et noir c'est un sujet de
michael burdell
moscou en plein hiver ces tempêtes de
neige sa place rouge essai - 15° un
froid glacial qui pourrait presque faire
frissonner les jupons d'une mariée à
l'autre bout de la ville c'est une autre
histoire c'est à l'université de
l'amitié entre les peuples que vit le
plus gros contingent d'africains ils
sont 5000 étudiants venus du nigeria du
sénégal ou encore du cameroun ils
représentent 40% des effectifs de la fac
et pour eux le premier choc et thermique
touché la neige pour la première fois
c'est comme jouer avec un glaçon dans le
congélateur joshua lui et nigérians et
fait déjà figure d'ancien son ami persie
lui vient juste d'arriver après quatre
années sur les bancs de l'école russe a
étudié les relations publiques je suis a
fini par dompter le climat
ici cette température ce n'est pas le
pire on a eu récemment - 25 - 30 c'était
glacial ce
vraiment oui il faisait plus froid
maintenant où ils plus froid c'était il
ya deux ou trois semaines - 25 - 25 ou
moins 30 même
si les blancs peuvent vivre ici et
survivre nous les noirs on peut le faire
aussi
[Musique]
après l'acclimatation la langue demeure
le principal obstacle de ces jeunes
étudiants africains pour joshua une
grosse tête deux mois seulement lui ont
suffi pour maîtriser les bases du russe
ce n'est pas l'information qui est
importante mais c'est ce qui est entre
les lignes vous avez compris
on passe au cinquième exercice
en 1960 date de la création de
l'université l'urss tente par tous les
moyens de contrer l'influencé de
l'occident dans le monde et cette
politique passe par l'afrique la
stratégie soviétique former les futurs
dirigeants des anciennes colonies
occidental pour leur inculquer les bases
du marxisme-léninisme aujourd'hui encore
ces relations diplomatiques entre la
russie et ses pays d'afrique sont
prépondérantes
pour eux il est prestigieux d'avoir une
formation russe
et quand il rentre au pays et peuvent
trouver un bon travail
obtenir ce diplôme de l'université de
l'amitié entre les peuples a une grande
valeur là bas
bonjour je suis à l'appel de la raison a
été le plus fort s'il a choisi moscou
pour faire ses études c'est avant tout
pour éviter d'être distraits par les
sirènes de la ville
quand les gens viennent étudier en
russie avant même de finir leurs études
ils veulent rentrer à la maison moi
aussi je veux déjà rentré chez moi alors
que quand les gens étudient en
angleterre par exemple ils font leurs
études et ne veulent plus rentrer il
reste vivre là bas la russie fabrique de
bons étudiants quai
à l'université de l'amitié entre les
peuples la première année d'étude est
entièrement dédié à l'apprentissage de
la langue les années suivantes sont
consacrées au cursus traditionnel
c'est la fin du cours pas une seconde à
faire pour joshua qui file à la réunion
des étudiants africains dont il est le
président
aia
je veux profiter de ce moment pour
discuter de la fête du 8 mars
combien ça va nous coûter qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
peut-être qu'on peut juste acheter des
boissons
entre les pays africains et la russie le
fossé culturel et profond ce décalage
les africains de moscou le prennent de
plein fouet et à des gens qui n'ont
jamais vu un noir ici enrichi je me
rappelle j'étais parti dans une ville c
est loin des riches et c'est une ville
qui s'appelle castro quand je suis venu
là bas les amoureux d'art et les amis
croyais que je suis un américain
passionné
photo x photographiée avec moi une
réaction naïve mais le choc des
civilisations ne se passe pas toujours
aussi bien ici en russie l'ultra
nationalisme est un vrai courant
politique des bandes de skinheads bras
armé de cette mouvance terrifie
régulièrement les étrangers
dernier cas en date l'assassinât d'un
jeune nigériens retrouvés poignardés et
les oreilles découper ce drame n'est
malheureusement pas un cas unique et les
agressions racistes sont fréquentes
dans l'intimité de sa résidence
universitaire joshua nous livre quelques
confidences sur le quotidien des
étudiants africains
l'administration de l'université nous a
avertis de ne pas nous éloigner de
l'établissement en particulier si l'on
est seul on doit faire attention quand
on sort et avec qui
il est toujours conseillé de sortir
accompagné de ne pas sortir le soir je
sais ce que les gens sont capables de
faire
je préfère rester ici les gens peuvent
venir n'importe quoi dans la alors je
préfère faire attention
c'est en 2006 que la russie a connu un
pic d'agressions racistes mais
aujourd'hui encore le climat délétère
oblige des étudiants africains à prendre
toutes leurs précautions
[Musique]
en dépit de cette insécurité certains
étudiants choisissent pourtant de rester
à moscou après leurs études la plupart
travaillent dans des ambassades
africaines ou son médecin
à l'intérieur de ce petit centre
commercial une clinique privée c'est ici
que travail daniel interne en
gynécologie
bonjour bonjour
comment allez vous très bien vous
appelez comment
natacha régnier en bout d'chou c'est
inhabituel d'avoir un docteur africain
mais si le médecin un bon contact la
couleur de sa peau n'est pas importante
daniel et nigérians il a fait ses études
de médecine à moscou tous les jours il
est confronté au regard parfois curieux
et parfois racistes des patients
je suis vous sculpter
il n'y a rien je ne vois rien
l'utérus évident
pour les patients chez soi et que je
commence à leur parler en russe ils sont
surpris
un médecin étranger parlant russe
ça on intéresse certains mais d'autre
part faire préfèrent garder leurs
distances
et ne rien avoir à faire avec un docteur
africain
aujourd'hui daniel a décidé de jeter
l'épongé
dans quelques mois il rentrera chez lui
au nigeria les opportunités
professionnelles et les salaires ils
sont bien meilleurs et la barre fini les
discriminations
d'autres africains plus rare encore ont
non seulement poser définitivement leurs
valises à moscou may ont même fondé une
famille
ceux là ont eu le coup de foudre pas
pour la russie mais pour une femme
entre sia thanh haï samuel histoire
commence il ya 20 ans à l'époque cet
étudiant en médecine tombe sous le
charme de cette jeune infirmière russe
avant la fin de ses études ce nigérian
deviens le papa d'une petite fille
depuis il est le chef d'une famille de
quatre enfants
allaient pousse toi toi david moi aussi
je veux refaire aller tout de suite
sinon tu vas voir
aller sous ce toit david et
c'est une femme de dieu une femme du
paradis
dès que je les ai vus je lui ai dit tu
seras ma femme noire
et ses skis à rien
mais pour s'être unis un noir en russie
sa femme svetlana a connu l'enfer
quand je prenais mes enfants en
poussette les gens venaient regarder
dans le landau il voulait voir ce qu'on
avait bien pu fabriquer et quand on
emmenait les enfants à la maternelle
tout le monde veut y aller regarder
quand je suis allé à l'école on m'a
traité de [ __ ] je suis rentré à la
maison contrarié maman m'a dit qu'il ne
fallait pas que j'y fasse attention que
c'étaient des idiots
honnêtement moi je les aurais tués oui
vraiment
avant j'étais toujours dans les jupes de
ma mère quand je me suis marié il a
fallu que je commence à me battre sortir
les griffes et mordre et maintenant je
suis devenu une vraie dame de fer
[Musique]
dans la russie d'aujourd'hui les couples
mixtes sont encore très marginaux siècle
anna et daniel eux n'ont aucun regret
leur futur s'écrira ici
depuis 50 ans l'état russe invite des
dizaines d'africains chaque année
arrivés sur place l'ads art academy peut
vite se transformer en goulag alors ici
la communautés supranationales
lino
[Musique]
face à l'adversité on n'est plus des
sénégalais des camerounais ou des
nigérians a moscou les noirs sont avant
tout des africains